Senator John McCain is fighting one of
the most dangerous forms of brain cancer
you reveal the diagnosis less than a
week after surgery to remove a blood
clot doctors at the Mayo Clinic Hospital
in Phoenix also removed a tumor called a
glioblastoma experts say this type of
cancer is aggressive and tough to treat
President Trump put out a statement of
support saying Senator John McCain has
always been a fighter get well soon and
former President Barack Obama who
defeated McCain in the 2008 election
called him an American Hero and tweeted
give it hell John Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill with a show of solidarity
from McCain Senate colleagues everyone
rooting for the Maverick Nancy that's
right and if you asked every senator up
here who among them is the toughest they
would all say John McCain but this is
exactly what they had been dreading that
the clot that was removed on Friday
might be linked to something more
serious that's gonna be a tough way
forward but he says I've been through
worse GOP senators were in a nighttime
meeting about health care when they
received the news about McCain's health
it was very emotional all of us were
giving him is very our very best
thoughts and wishes it kind of puts puts
things in perspective
South Carolina's Lindsey Graham is
McCain's best friend in the Senate God
knows how this ends not me
but I do know this this disease has
never had a more worthy opponent the
diagnosis helps explain what Graham
noticed was some recent fatigue and
forgetfulness in the case of mr. call me
you the president called me serves me a
case of President Trump glioblastoma is
the same type of brain cancer that
felled another legend of the Senate Ted
Kennedy in 2009 and Joe Biden's son Beau
in 2015 the former vice president
tweeted last night John and I have been
friends for 40 years he's gotten through
so much difficulty with so much grace he
is strong and he will beat this McCain
has faced cancer scares before he has
had four melanomas or skin cancer
lesions removed since 1993 the most
recent was in 2002
your--okay plasti that surgery you have
yes yes just fine just fine absolutely I
go every three months to my
dermatologist McCain's colleagues
insisted he can weather this too after
all they say the 80 year old former Navy
pilot endured five-and-a-half years as a
prisoner of war and 34 years in the US
Congress not to mention two runs for
president I get a straight talk from my
daughter like what anything I do wrong
Megan McCain wrote last night that the
family has endured the shock of the news
and now we live with the anxiety about
what comes next
I cannot and do not wish to be in a
world without him McCain's doctors say
his treatment could include chemotherapy
and radiation but we don't yet know
charlie whether that would take place at
home in Phoenix or here in Washington
thanks Nancy